I think China will continue this
momentum to grow I think we're actually
kind of sort of like go back to the uh
culture Revolution kind of era
[Music]
when Xi Jinping came to power a decade
ago he inherited a China that was Rising
economically and diplomatically but
under his watch it's become less open
and more conservative
I traveled to Chongqing a major landmark
in cheese rise to power to see how the
city and its people have changed in the
past decade and to find out what it can
tell us about China's next 10 years this
municipality is the size of Austria and
the place where she ousted his main
leadership rival boshilai
today Chongqing has undergone a
population and construction boom that
some say masks are backsliding in
freedoms
others like 33 year old education
entrepreneur Huang Yi see it differently
I definitely feel China is becoming
stronger I thought I'm getting more
attention
in the peer group
and our living environment becomes more
International and convenient
huangi's former employer new Oriental
fired 60 000 staff in the wake of she's
Crackdown on private tutoring all in the
name of common prosperity
it is their responsibility to make the
decision for the business for the
industry for the public and I think it's
necessary for them to have this
regulation policies
if they think they are right for the
public
this instagramable bookstore has a
shrine-like display of books dedicated
to she while English language shelves at
most bookshops in China have been
shrinking she has been reshaping the
country's education system putting
greater emphasis on patriotic study and
downplaying the importance of foreign
languages
32 year old Yang who studied abroad
asked for his identity not to be
revealed
especially from the Western news that
our president doesn't really want as
young kids to learn English anymore
because they don't really want you to
have like this language tool to get to
know you know what the outside world was
like the changes are part of a series of
education related moves aimed at
ensuring future Generations remain loyal
to the party which celebrated its 100th
anniversary in July 2021. I think my
experience of studying abroad exposed me
to this new way of critical thinking or
maybe creative thinking hanging out with
my peers and whenever we encounter like
something like political issues of
course they disagree with me the
Communist party was weakened by Decades
of corruption and decentralization
during the boom years
since then she's campaigned to claw back
control has made him China's most
powerful man since Mao Zedong
but it's come at the expense of Social
and economic freedoms
and China's great firewall which blocks
foreign ideas from the internet has been
bolstered by the physical closing of
borders during the pandemic
zero code policy or something like that
how can you battle a virus you're gonna
have to live with it
the impact of this is being seen on the
economy lockdowns mean China is unlikely
to meet it's already watered down goal
of 5.5 growth this year
youth unemployment reached almost 20
percent in July and the property sector
faces some of its most serious
challenges yet after the kosher
Revolution people are like being I would
say brainwash to be like super
competitive everything is aiming for
fame money and property and everything
like we kind of lost that really really
good Chinese characters of course I hope
my business goes well I hope there would
be policies which would benefit my
business but I would respect the
government's decision
she has sought to narrow the nation's
wealth Gap in his bid to build a
prosperous and strong society and while
covet zero may be weighing on the
economy for now it's also kept the death
toll far below that scene elsewhere